at this altitude I can this episode is
brought to you by a scent protein I am
really excited about this discovery I
became aware of these guys when I found
out that they'd spent 5 years trying to
manufacture a better version of whey
protein and the result is something
called native proteins which represents
cleaner pure less processed protein so
here's a mini-tutorial
there are only a handful of companies
worldwide that can extract native
proteins directly from milk traditional
whey protein what you've probably bought
before is a byproduct of making cheese
so a company must have the resources
know-how and a large customer base to
invest in extracting proteins directly
from the milk without the ability to
also profit from the associated cheese
that means the net-net is native
proteins are super rare so a scent is
the only us-based company that offers
native proteins both way and micellar
casein directly to the consumer they're
able to do that because the parent
company l'p RINO is a huge cheese
manufacturer they've been filtering
proteins for more than 30 years and
there are a few important things to take
away from this number one zero
artificial ingredients that is a solid
claim it's much stricter than all
natural number two they've done
extensive testing so the chocolate which
I've been using after every workout and
also in the mornings was finalized after
282 recipes were vetted and perhaps most
important I talked about less processed
they avoid steps like bleaching and this
is important to understand so it's it's
a very big deal but hasn't yet caught on
for Sports Nutrition traditional whey
proteins are a byproduct of cheese
making like I mentioned many of the
proteins are therefore orange in color
because they were sourced from say
cheddar cheese production because
companies can't sell or
powders vanilla or strawberry they have
to bleach the proteins wipe this harms
the proteins and leaves trace amounts of
bleach in the product that is no bueno
no good infant formula companies for
instance have banned the use of bleached
proteins already in in their products
and that is why a sense parent company
Lupino foods is the number one supplier
of protein to infinite formula companies
so all that said if you want cleaner
pure less processed protein which I
certainly do and I'm really excited to
be using this protein and I just ran out
of chocolate so I need another bag check
it out go to a scent protein com forward
slash Tim that's a s C ent protein calm
ascent protein calm forward-slash Tim
and you can receive 20% off of your
entire order if you want a quick 25 gram
dose to start your day for instance
you're following slow carb diet or after
a workout this is a great option they
also have micellar casein which is
slower release and you can check that
out so take a look go to a scent protein
calm forward-slash Tim this episode is
brought to you by 4 Sigma Dec founded by
the genius Finn's who lit the internet
on fire and you may have heard of their
mushroom coffee which features chaga and
lion's mane which has taken Silicon
Valley by storm I use it pretty much
every day either that or the chaga which
is decaf as a separate version and I use
both of these primarily for focus and
productivity they just get you going let
you up like a Christmas tree so you
should definitely check it out people
are always asking me what I use for
cognitive enhancement and for right now
this is the answer I try to force this
on all of my houseguests it is a hell of
a thing if I have employees or people
come over who aren't working on projects
with me I always try to feed it to them
because I'm going to get the limitless
effect get a lot more out of them the
first time I mentioned this product and
for sig Matic on the podcast their
products sold out in less than a week so
you may want to check them out soon if
you're listening to this and the coffee
tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water
and oddly enough only includes 40
milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner in my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic calm
forward slash Tim that's four sig Matic
fo you are SI g ma TI c calm forward
slash Tim and use the code
Tim TI m to get 20% off of your first
order and they're not that expensive
anyway if you are in the experimental
mindset I do not think you'll be
disappointed to try them up
Wow you sexy little minx oh stop it this
is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show and
parents are you have to define minx for
your children listening in the car
during the drive to school but so it
goes that's how the cards have fallen
his fine job to deconstruct world-class
performers on the show and we do that in
many different areas whether they come
from say the military from entertainment
from research from sports
you've can spot common patterns and my
job is to tease out the details the
philosophy is the habits that you can
use this episode features bill Rasmussen
at bill underscore ESPN on Twitter I'll
keep this short because we want to jump
right into it bill is the founder of
ESPN and the creator of the 24 hour
programming cycle that all networks use
today I was really excited to be able to
sit down with them and we really
recorded a lot we recorded three hours
of material and only one hour was used
for my new TV show which I'm going to
get to in a second and this podcast
episode is almost entirely new exclusive
content that did not appear on the TV
show the TV show if you want to check it
out is fearless with less in parentheses
because the goal is not to be fearless
but to learn to fear less where I
interview people like this world class
performers about how they've overcome
doubt fear and made their toughest
decisions you can watch the entire first
episode with illusionist and endurance
artist david blaine for free at att.net
forward slash fearless I highly
recommend you check it out it's awesome
and he does a lot on stage and to watch
all of the episodes there are 10 of them
you can go to tim dot blog forward slash
fearless just type it all out no
parenthesis tim vlog forward slash
fearless and you can select your option
if you're a cord cutter if you use
computers instead of tvs you can just
click on directv now and all of the
packages have it too so you can choose
the cheapest one or the free trial to
take a look and that is it so without
further ado please enjoy my wide-ranging
conversation with bill Rasmussen
welcome to fearless I'm your host Tim
Ferriss and on this stage we will be
deconstructing world-class performers of
all types to uncover the specific
tactics and strategies they've used to
overcome doubt tackle hard decisions and
ultimately succeed by show of hands how
many people here wait for say the
morning paper to get their sports scores
it's a big fat zero how many of you can
remember when television wasn't
available 24 hours a day anyone all
right of my generation they're a little
bit older got a few hands
and when I say Bristol Connecticut what
do you think of after meeting my guest
tonight you'll associate it with one
thing and that is sports
against all odds heat set out to change
the course of television and the status
quo as we know it and in the process he
created one of the most iconic and
recognizable brands in the world please
welcome the founder of ESPN bill
Rasmussen
what was your grandfather like describe
for us your relationship with your
grandfather he was literally a
dyed-in-the-wool White Sox fan he took
me to Comiskey Park when I was very very
young and I can remember
he lived if you're familiar with Chicago
35th Street it was 35th and Shields is
where the Comiskey Park was and he lived
at 33rd and bail I can remember these
details like I can't believe it's there
there and he would walk me to the
streetcar and say now when all the
people start getting off here at the
ballpark like I wouldn't know where the
ballpark was there it is right from me
and I can remember finding out early and
this is in the early 1940s the the
ballpark would open it was 1 o'clock
game there was they open the gates at 11
o'clock and my goal was always to be
there to be one day be the first one in
the ballpark and one day I did do it and
my grandmother would give me a sandwich
and a little coke bottle with those
little green bottles I would take that
off another on to the streetcar nickel
or whatever was to go on the streetcar
and get off Comiskey Park and be in
there one day they were worried
Red Sox and White Sox played a
doubleheader first game went 13 innings
and the second one went to the bottom of
the ninth both games were 7 to 6 and it
took you know half a day to play all
that I didn't leave I was there from 2
hours before the first pitch to the end
of the second game and my grandfather
allowed us how at that point I became an
official White Sox fan so anything
allowed as long as it's Whiteside as
long as we're late as well then it was
really it's only a two blocks here you
reciting these statistics one of the
first thoughts that jumped to mind was
you'd make a really good intelligence
officer and then I thought of something
that I had heard which was you played
war games as a kid am I making this up
or did you have oh yeah we used to well
everybody did okay I mean when 1941
occurred I was in the fourth grade and
before I think before Christmas were all
talking about
everybody everybody in America was
talking about
all have to be together there were no
right left up down or anything we were
all on the same same team and at the
early part of the war before they
started saying you couldn't do this I
can remember my father's shirts come
back from the cleaners with a piece of
cardboard in pretty much like they do
today I suppose some some places then
and we used to draw whatever we wanted
to do if I was going to be a master
sergeant for the games the next day we
would draw it on a board then color it
with crayons you know red and green and
blue or whatever it was cut them out
with rubber bands we put them on our
arms and off we'd go over the next day
to do whatever battle we had decided we
were doing and we did that basically all
through the war it was kind of crazy but
we had to start using other things
because hangers and cardboard were all
confiscated we went out of little risk
in it oh yeah they had everything went
to the war effort we picked up
newspapers everything went and was we
didn't use they didn't use the word
recycle then but that's what it was they
were recycling everything and producing
the other thing it's great pretty cool
do you remember where you were when you
heard about Pearl Harbor absolutely what
I was at 95 55 South Melvina Avenue in
Columbus manner
just south of 92 today back then 95th
Street was highway 12 and 20 on the
south side chicago two lanes one in each
direction today is 12 lanes six in each
direction but my happened and my father
got us all around the radio and we said
we sat literally on the living-room
floor watching the radio listening to
news reports and we were not unique yep
happened all across America so if we
flash forward just a little bit to say
high school and look at your experience
in high school played baseball did you
try any other sports oh yeah I tried
football once cuz my father encouraged
me to do that because that was really
fast yeah had football go forth well I
was so fast one afternoon i intercepted
a pass you wouldn't even maybe you would
understand some of the football
technology today we had defensive half
backs and we had we didn't have all of
these white outs and slots and safe but
very different things anyway I was a
defensive halfback intercepted the pass
and because I was so fast I went around
very quickly I didn't see anybody in
front of me and I thought what a great
this is really gonna be great
touchdown was in sight and I woke up
under the bench what happened somebody
was faster than I was and when they were
faster than I was and I went it when
it's not expected and you get tackled
from behind I was literally like lights
out
game over football career over that was
it done so did you was it was it your
choice to end the football or did you
okay that doesn't happen with baseball
but then I did find out playing baseball
one day in a practice we were just doing
an inter-squad game and I turned around
you know what the cardinal rule is in
baseball never ever take your eye off
the ball right right and if you're
playing and never ever take your eye off
law I went like this one time and turned
back and that's all it goes and I said
turn back I get it right in the face
with baseball and maybe that's why well
no we're not going to go what that's why
I looked this way today my nose is more
crooked than yours maybe I got hit by a
baseball and don't remember it actually
I don't actually know I did this is true
so I remember my first day Little League
tryouts his deep in left field flyball
right in the middle of the face so that
was the end of my baseball career that
would be embarrassing for an outfielder
oh and anything fielder especially is
whenever I was a third or fourth grader
was the runt of the litter as it was now
I have lack of hand-eye coordination to
go with it it was terrible
tell me about a little bit about high
school in doing research I read about an
essay contest that ended up sending you
ultimately to me suppose the the
president or soon to be President could
you describe that for us and I was a
junior in high school in 1948 start my
junior year that September and there was
a Chicago Sun Times had an essay contest
for all students that six of from the
city were going to be chosen to go to
President Harry Truman's inauguration
that was the famous election where the
Chicago Tribune put out the headline do
we
wins and then Truman held up the paper
the next day his picture was and they're
holding up the picture of the newspaper
and of course do we didn't win but the
deal was we'd write an essay and so on
and my father decided to I could write
an essay on becoming a lawyer I was
going to become a lawyer and I must have
done a really persuasive job on why I
wanted to be a lawyer because I was one
of the six winners and we got to go to
Washington we got to sit on the the
Capitol whatever I'm not sure what they
call it but up there with all the
dignitaries of diets or whatever yeah
well you know it's where the Senators
the representatives were included in
that and there were six of us and
watched Harry Truman take his oath of
office in the morning I got to watch him
it take the actual earth we were we were
right there in 1949 that we went that
night of course they have all these
different parties and one of the things
that stands out we're all 16 year old
kids we were chaperoned everywhere we
went and we were standing at the
Shoreham Hotel and I turned to my left
in general Omar Bradley was standing
right there and he put out his hand said
hi how are you you know what are you
doing here and general Omar Bradley was
a an icon to the people of that era it
was unknown and I have never forgotten
that so we were able to maintain your
composure through all of that I mean you
get flown to the president or soon to be
present of being sworn in then you turn
you see an icon on the other side were
you able to maintain your composure
through all of that yeah I think I was
just numb through it all I didn't even
just even register you know no I mean
obviously I knew who he was and then I
was very we were all very honored to be
selected so you get to college and were
there any particular teachers there
there too I've read about history and
econ but were there any particular
teachers had a large impact on you the
the one professor in economics financial
organization and investment was they he
was the head of the the Economics
Department dr. Joel me and he was an
interesting gentleman to say the least
if you weren't paying attention he had a
great arm he should have been a
shortstop I don't think these schools
exist this way today but we used to have
blackboard all the way across the front
of the room and all the way down the
side of the room and he would start at
the class over here at the left hand
side putting things up and talking it's
on Ana lecturing and his suit would get
all covered with chalk dust and so on
then he turned around out of nowhere and
he'd say Tim what about whatever the
question was if you didn't get it he'd
take that eraser and he'd hit him in the
forehead we'd hit in the shoulder and
your mark was if you came out of the
class with no chalk marks on it was a
successful afternoon and I can also just
to put it in a little perspective I
remember the day the Dow Jones average
hit 3,000 and you know how we used to
get there was no on line followed by a
minute by minute he would bring in after
the market closed the the Wall Street
Journal would publish everything in
printed form and he would bring that in
the next day and that's how we learned
about stock market crazy stuff and was
there another professor who did
reenactments oh yeah Andrew Crandall dr.
Crandall he was a actually it was a
noted Civil War expert in the country
and every year he would the only place
big enough to hold his lectures if you
will was was named Mitchell Hall the
chemistry laboratory with all of the the
theater types eights and donphan and he
would set up huge tables and reenact the
Battle of Gettysburg or whatever it was
and he had little it was like kids toys
really he was so engrossed in he too he
would start off with a certain time and
cotan before long as the war as the
battle progressed raging and they were
standing room only lectures it was just
amazing people wanted to see because he
was entertaining but so knowledgeable
about the Civil War and he created an
awareness and so many students about
that period in our history that I can
remember it very very vividly he was
he was an enthusiastic and a very very
knowledgeable person about it all and we
talked about Pickett's charge or robert
e lee doing this and grant doing i mean
it was it was incredible I never missed
one for years I seem to recall and you
can you can shoot this down as a figment
of my imagination a stint as you had a
lot of different gigs and part-time gigs
that seemed as a collection to really
informed what you did later the ESPN did
you not have some experiences of
weatherman oh yeah oh is that fun and
you and you started inserting things
into the weather well what what happened
is coming yeah I well first of all you
had to understand why I ended why I even
end up at the station talking about
being a weatherman I lived in Amherst
Massachusetts and there were only you
have to remember now this is in 1964
1965 we had two stations once NBC
station one ABC station that's all the
television there was in the entire
western part of Massachusetts the NBC
station had news weather and sports from
11 to 11 verse 7 to 7:30 and 11 to 11:30
the ABC station at 11 o'clock just did
15 minutes news and signed off so I said
I'm not going to get the guys job at the
one that does 11 out a half-hour at
11:00 why don't I go talk to the station
managers at the ABC station and tell him
he needs a sports show it's part of that
confidence I guess and so I went and met
him call for an appointment I said sure
come on down said what is it you want to
do I said well the other guys are doing
sports you should be doing sports yeah
we don't like this place so we talked to
one he said well all right all right
you've been I'll pay it $10 a show I had
to drive 40 miles to get there 20 miles
40 miles round-trip it's a net loss yeah
so it's a net loss so and you can start
Monday
okay well I knew I could do sports so
I'll get down there and I'm walking in
the door on Monday whatever was the 3rd
of January the 5th of January and he
said changed my mind I see what you mean
you've change I thought I was fired and
I wasn't fired he said you're gonna do
the weather we're not gonna do sports
you're gonna do the weather I said
anything about weather shoveling snow
doesn't qualify you to you know he said
here's the way we're gonna do the
weather you call Bradley field talk to
they know of the national weather people
that Bradley field call them around
10:30 find out what the world looks like
around you know this is a general area
scratch a few things we didn't have
klystron nines and all of these kinds of
things back then we had a grease pencil
and a whiteboard and write something
down draw a picture of Springville if
you like or Massachusetts and just say
it's gonna be 68 degrees in rain
tomorrow that's that's all people are
going to get so I can and I can remember
and just to digress for a second this is
some 9 or 10 thousand live shows a goal
but this is the very first one I can
remember when they said one minute I
turned around put my back to the camera
and the sweat running down the center of
my back and I remember saying why am i
subjecting myself to this then they
turned said you know ten seconds five
four I turned around and I decided every
like this this is pretty good stuff I'm
gonna be telling people about the
weather and I decided just I had
followed the Springfield Indians hockey
team in the American Hockey League and
they Boston Bruins and the Rangers
everybody in the area so I said what
we're gonna do is we're gonna find the
weather from different cities especially
where the Springfield team was playing
and say tonight it's 32 degrees in
Pittsburgh and you know light snow
falling and the Indians won three to two
and I would just write three to two
I'll get so I thought this was get me
fired for sure yeah so you didn't ask
this was a forgiveness out permission oh
yeah forget oh it's much easier -
forgiveness
so that's what we did and the next day I
didn't see the general manager didn't
say anything so the next night I did a
couple more scores and the next day I
found out some people called the station
and said you know this new Sports idea
and whether they thought it was if they
thought of that because it was a planned
gig but it wasn't it just happened great
and collaborative innovation yeah and
then the gentlemen at the NBC station
was promoted went down to Charlotte
North Carolina and before he left
because he had obviously we had met
along the way because competitors do
that and he recommended me for that job
and then the things happen for a good
reason
kind of thing I went up to that station
and I was only doing the weather and the
sports for about four months then I went
to the other station the NBC station
start doing sports and it happened to be
in the year that Muhammad Ali and Sonny
Liston fought in Lewiston Maine big
fight and his headquarters were in
Chicopee Massachusetts and I was the guy
able to go down and I met him back then
and we met each other several times
after that but you never know I mean
here was a station that wasn't doing
something I talked him into something I
guess or they decided they were gonna do
it and then the other guy leaves and I
get his job and all of a sudden
listening and back then I was Cassius
Clay we're gonna add this big fight I
can tell you and people who know Cassius
Clay you know pretty bummed
bombastic person and he was we had a
lunch in one day and he was his usual
self when he who said he was going
upstairs was a long way that from where
his training camp was to the station so
I decided to stay there I just sat in
the lobby in an hour so after lunch I I
was kind of dozing off waiting for the
four o'clock press conference and I
sense somebody sitting down over here
and it's
explai are you doing what do you know we
said that we talked for probably an hour
normal tones just a just a great guy we
were just gives a young guy obviously
and we were he said well I guess I
better go up we're gonna do this four
o'clock right and I was they didn't call
it that but I was quote the question
asker the pool announcer I was gonna ask
all the questions and he was gonna
answer for everything for everybody so
has that seen a little while yeah good
looking forward to it
few minutes later white suit white shoes
white shirt white tie big everybody Wow
here he come came dad he looked right
through me like he had never even seen
me before
did his press conference with all the
usual bombast that he did and I've never
forgotten that and I saw many years
later and he remembered it he put on a
stage so it on and he put on a show he
would but he was he was it was quite a
guy I was privileged to meet him what
most what were the most memorable
aspects of that encounter to you the
fact that he could turn it on turn it
off that way turn it off and his
personality and he was really I mean he
talked just like you and I are talking
wasn't it wasn't it wasn't I'm the champ
and you're just a guy here in
Massachusetts it wasn't that at all and
I never forgot that and I saw many many
years later and the st. man it was the
same way you mentioned something just a
minute ago the things happen for a
reason is that a core belief of yours
and the things happen for reason has it
always been maybe we make it happen and
sometimes it just happens if you had to
say teach let's just call it you can
pick the grade 9th grade class college
class doesn't really matter to help
students develop confidence what how
would you approach that or how would you
even think about it yeah you know this a
lot of people ask me that question and
I'm not it's gonna sound odd I'm not
sure I'm qualified to do that in the
form of a college curriculum mm-hmm but
if I can somehow transmit the belief or
the feeling of success and
positive approach to things that you
have to have and be able to take the
negatives and get past them mm-hmm and I
know how you do that in a college
curriculum but it's I just you know
whether it's stealing bases or selling
products or whatever as I said earlier I
think they when somebody says no they've
made the mistake and I don't I don't
know how you I don't know how I would do
that the other leg of the table it seems
is advertising so you shortly
I don't know if it was shortly after but
after getting the n-c-double-a to commit
ahead of that little ads yeah we were we
were floating them a little they were
one of them so we told him who we were
talking to we didn't tell them we had
this is a well-known beer company I
suppose it is
and so can you tell us a little bit
about how that was was that happening
concurrently was that no ball in the air
yeah that was happening in early January
okay we had hired as an advertiser Bush
yeah we had hired a gentleman from
Connecticut general insurance to be our
general sales manager he was the general
sales manager there like the sports idea
and I said we have to be obvious the
obvious choice is anheuser-busch largest
sports advertiser in the world then and
maybe today I don't know but we had a
very specific plan to take them that
sounds odd when I say all these other
vagaries that were just juggling but we
had a very specific plan we decided that
if we could get eight sponsors a two
million seven hundred and sixty thousand
dollars a year that would finance a
total of eight the sum total of the
eight sponsors no no total eight times
so it'd be 20 oh okay got it got it so
we went down to New York got invited
down to Darcy McManus and the vice
president Jane Petrella was his name he
listened and who's at rege he has to be
intrigued it's his business sports
business budweis he said I'll take you
to the brewery I'll get back to you a
couple days later we went back down to
New York and he said I've been to the
brewery we'll give you a $500,000 that's
the first sign we ever had of anybody
coming our way our 9,000 going out the
door my family and friends are going out
the door
OKs we to put some money in we were
we were running this was the first black
gank like real influence this yeah and
Bob and I looked at each other and we
shook our heads and said and this just I
was sitting right the way I'm sitting
with you Tim and as you know in New York
out windows they're advertising things
on the sides of buildings on the front
of buildings and marquees and everywhere
and it just so happened over jeans left
shoulder was a big ad for Miller Miller
High Life and I looked at Bob and he
looked at me and I took my eyes from
Jean and I said we can't accept that and
we were gonna have to pursue other
evidence and I just looked over that way
and he said before you do that he knew
he knew what ad was out that window he
said let me have this exact word let me
have another go at the brewery he called
a couple days later and he said I'll
tell you what nobody's ever done this in
cable television we'll give you a
million three hundred eighty thousand
dollars and let's go and that's the way
it was so we had a million three hundred
eighty committed before we had the
programming committee and then before we
had the financing committed what's gonna
you know when all the eggs are running
it doesn't make any difference which
order they come in did you get them all
in what were some of the more say costly
decisions or missteps that you guys had
early on yeah yeah well we did we did
Canadian football we tried to do some we
tried to do a lot of different things
with different we always tried to
overreach and even to this day just a
couple years ago I was in Dallas talking
to ESPN radio which by the way is now
the biggest radio network you know it's
just crazy and I asked that very same
question about what happens and what are
the mistakes this fellow had worked for
ABC and so I said what's the difference
between the two same market he worked
for ABC now he's working for ESPN
because obviously they were all bought
by Disney and they're all in the same
house so to speak
he said ABC always sent out directives
to us saying
don't rock the boat we're doing well in
this market we're doing well here we're
doing all these they don't rock the boat
ESPN on the other hand
says try everything that pops into your
mind if it works great if it doesn't
forget it and move on to totally
different approaches
sounds like the bill Rasmussen guide to
life that's like the mantra right there
well but but think about that yeah how
discouraging it would be to your
employees to say I don't want you coming
and telling me anything you might have a
great it I don't want to hear your great
idea after you've given them an
opportunity to work for you now you
don't want to hear from them so
encourage everybody in let's let's do it
all and if you met so what if you mess
up nobody's gonna shoot you there's no
debtors jail there's no you know no
guillotine this isn't whatever and I
thought that was interesting from them
they've tried a number of things we did
a thing with not when I was there but
with cell phones when they first came in
there was some gigantic program when
they were testing it with kids of all
the employees and everything else it
didn't work so they just moved on of
course they've changed that around a
little bit now with screaming and
everything else in cell phones today of
course a little different than they were
ten years ago did we even have cell
phones ten years ago I don't even
remember we did they just they were
closer to the Gordon Gecko yeah brick
okay but yes we did have those what I'd
love to do we're talking about of course
ESPN arguably you're best known for that
but to sort of bring it full circle for
a second we're gonna bring out a prop
it's not really a prop this is this is a
real real thing a real thing I don't
want to spoil the surprise so we're
gonna get that that's gonna come out but
I thought we might do if the team in the
back can bring up the then and now some
of the stats because you mentioned radio
mmm-hmm I just thought just to put this
in perspective for people starting with
irish hurling and juggling five
different balls telling everyone each
person that everyone else is in until
ultimately you get them all in I think
it's it's pretty staggering when you
look at the before and after and if you
so I'm not going to read all these stats
for you guys but you can see subscribers
1.3 million to more than 90 million
80 employees more than 8,000 then one
acre just in Bristol alone 223 radio
none - 20 million and that's not even
counting the publishing arm no huge
magazine and everything else yeah it's
an amazing there subscriber fees this is
a staggering number to me
we started off asking for a penny day
one penny would you pay me Tim if I came
to you and I said Tim forgive me a penny
day 30 cents a month then you can watch
sports 24 hours a day I give you that
idea
does that sound good that's the house
kid got turned down got left out as a
matter of fact degress from one of those
people that I said you can make money
doing this I said not only that we're
gonna give you local availabilities I
got this funny look like what's the
local availability I was gonna ask you
yeah well what we're gonna do is on ESPN
we'll pause and you can put in a local
sponsor Joe's pizza
somebody's Sam's Toyota or whatever in
your market and your telecast new excel
him advertised know what the answer was
why would I want to do that I kind of
did just what you said like this what he
said I'd have to hire somebody to go
sell I said here's a knight and I did
very this that was probably rude I
shouldn't have done this but I did it
because it's a knee-jerk reaction to me
so here's an idea
he sells a hundred he keeps 10 and you
get 90 oh well maybe we can talk again
well now today that back then cable the
cable systems didn't make much money
advertising today it's a multi-billion
dollar business as you know they just
make all kinds of money so let's let's
bring in what I mentioned before so if
we could bring in what we have here I'll
do my best to hold this let me fall
apart keep the pieces made fall apart
you tell us what this is please this is
a this is the latest and greatest 12 at
the time a third basement in 1947 this
is my original baseball glove in high
school when I was a high school
sophomore and if you can see it I don't
try to put your hand in there Tim as if
you were playing
I'll be the guy who destroys it on
national television
can you imagine catching balls with that
it was that was not the easiest thing
yeah this looks like Cookie Monster now
you know
here's another baseball fans of the day
this was what you had to do when the
inning was over you turned around and
you threw your glove back onto the
outfield grass major leagues did it we
did it
say that again I didn't know this all
virtually all through the first half
century when the infielders came off the
field or the outfielders they never
brought their glove in with him into the
dugout they left him the third baseman
drop is long the foul line shortstop to
throw his in short left field second
baseman into a right field why nobody I
mean today there's so if there's a I
don't know a Kleenex blows across field
timeout and you have to get out and
clean and here they were just littering
the field with their own gloves but what
amazes me I found this in some storage
obviously this was absolutely the most
expensive thing I had ever had in my
life to do with baseball at that point
in nineteen it was be the spring of 1947
and I look at the gloves today softball
gloves are so much better than this and
I don't know how I ever
I don't know how everybody didn't have
about a 500 fielding average because how
we caught things ever though that's
pretty amazing though and I'm really
pleased with that because it does bring
back lots of memories did you collect
anything as a kid you know what did you
collect anything as a kid did you
clicked no statistics statistics I was
into we had a we had a little board game
where he spun an arrow and I would you
know they sent out but I think maybe was
one of the bubblegum companies that paid
this little game and whoever they had
other cards they'd make the all-star
team for the nationally numerically they
give me a spin and make up games and
percentages and do all that I was
forever drawing little things I remember
my father worked at the Ford aircraft
engine division and during the war and
he brought me home what do they call a
mimeograph scorecards and I would use
those score
cards and play a game in 8 or 9 or 10
minutes and fill in a score card that
throw that one he'd start all over again
and I was just I guess now that I think
about it I had a pretty long obsession
with statistics if you were to give
advice to yourself on the day before
ESPN launched not necessarily about the
next day but just any advice whatsoever
would you would you give yourself any
advice I probably would have hoped that
we were a little farther along going on
the air I would I always want to be the
next step and it didn't turn out that
the next step would have been a lot
better because everything turned out
pretty well
are there any pitches that come to mind
that were complete disasters complete
failures yeah any I certainly can
thought I mean I've have my fair share
I'm just wondering it with regard to
ESPN or already
anything just oh yeah entrepreneurs
start lots of businesses convinced that
everything's gonna work fine I did the
radio networks for Massachusetts
University of Massachusetts and then
expand it they're doing basketball that
works in hockey head works every time I
thought they were really good somebody
to say well we're not gonna do that
anymore and I said okay and you know
that's the way it is obviously you're
disappointed you know but you can't stop
living it's not the end of the world I
mean you keep eating yeah that's all
there is to it and I don't know if it's
if it's luck if it's coincidence if it's
I don't know what whenever I've had a
moment to come we had a we had a home
automation company that we bought into
long before all of the technology could
make it really happen it's not a good
idea
it sounded like a great idea at the time
but you know what we tried it didn't
work mm-hmm push this out and keep on
going so you you've been thought of this
for instance with the n-c-double-a as a
sort of not Nostradamus of college
sports right because you
you got the programming and then lo and
behold we have Larry Bird Magic Johnson
all of a sudden it's the rage right yeah
and it seems like certainly I've seen
this a lot where I live in Silicon
Valley that you've had a lot of great
bets but some of them like the home
automation have been early and you've
paddles for too long really yeah how do
you how do you think about evaluating
opportunities like that I mean you've
made plenty of investments well well
what I what I think about is obviously
we all think about the success a bit of
a I might think about success a little
bit differently you know we put together
a business plan right what's your what's
your mission statement have you ever
seen mission statements sure page long
300 I know you have but I mean some of
our page long some are three paragraphs
they get beyond 10 or 12 words I think
we've lost focus
yes PN to this day you know what their
mission statement is six words six words
thrive ESPN to serve sports fans anytime
anywhere that's it does that say if I
can't reduce it to some simple that I
can see it let's make it work this way
we're involved in a new business now it
sounds funny at my age right I'm an old
but I'm not that old I'm not too older
want to do things your brain works 10
times faster than mine so yeah I've no
sympathy but this has to do with
streaming what do I know about streaming
I didn't know anything about satellites
but I'll find out but I don't have to
know about streaming you dream it we
stream it how's that six words
works six words good statement good good
mission statement but but really isn't
everything that we all undertake if you
decide you're gonna go to the movie at
the SEC pick a good movie that you want
to go see you can pick the wrong one
what do you do well we'll try again or
do you go home and say I'm never going
the movies again because that didn't
work when you make an investment how do
you decide how big it is and do you cap
the down
is there a point where you say all right
you know what this this isn't where we
want it to be I'm gonna cut my losses
how do you think through that I I think
that there I think you have to set a
threshold if you will and it's both
upper and lower
mm-hmm I always think the sky's the
limit
but you have to think at the bottom and
if it's not going to work take your
medicine and and check out that's all in
the wrong there's I can't tell you how
many things now many time how many cars
do you buy and then of course were like
when you go into the day you buy the car
oh you're so oh this is perfect this all
and what two years later the only view
slapping things around the car you throw
things in the trunk or something on the
front seat you know very much sense to
do it and then pretty soon you don't
don't want that car anymore we have to
get another new car
sorry that was gone so you cut your
losses you get rid of that I want to get
into it
mmm and that would life is all about
really what what's your choice what are
we gonna do in the next hour what are we
gonna do the next day or the week or the
month that follows then I've just been
I'm a positive I approach life from a
positive side and when you say it's a
loss and how do you cut your losses sure
you would rather not do that mmm it's
not the end of the world
yeah part of the education part of the
education what so when you look at I
mean you've used your time very well I
mean clearly putting together ESPN just
to make that series of miracles happen
can't depend on a miracle I mean you had
some good timing but you made a lot of
good decisions when you were at your
peak when you're just a machine what did
your days or weeks look like how did you
manage your time I mean maybe the better
question is how did you do things
differently what I would do is every day
with if I had to meet you someplace you
were on the schedule tomorrow you you
were the next thing that I was gonna do
but seven other things might come up in
between and I'd have to figure out how
to do them and someone might put back -
after you answer and I really it sounds
fun it's not that funny it sounds like
maybe I'm like that pinball machine I'm
going from here to here but each one of
those stops had meaning in of some sort
back in the soliciting cable operators
time we
there was a book back then called
standard rate and data service there was
no longer remember that you remember
that I do big book mm-hmm we would look
up sports directors or radio or
president of presidents of cable system
we decided we were just gonna go pitch
the top 20 cable systems two of us split
I took the top first ten the next guy ed
Egan was the name took the next ten and
we had a young lady sitting in our
hallway and our off that was her office
was in the hallway outside two offices
we only had two and we had her call each
of those cable operators and say here in
Los Angeles but there was one we'd say
you know bill is gonna be in Los Angeles
on Thursday and would like to meet with
Tim at two o'clock I don't know who Tim
is I don't don't even know where your
office is I'm gonna have to get out
there and find a map and find you we did
that
she called ten cable system the 10
biggest cable system at the time all ten
of them took a meeting all 10 of them so
five of them were in Denver and I just
went right down the street and met with
them all kept those kinds of things
don't be a don't be afraid to try crazy
things yeah I mean who would have
thought something like that would work
I'd probably be saving what what happens
today if your cell phone rings my phone
number says unknown I don't answer it
don't answer
does anybody answer not me I have two of
those today yeah hang out so now here we
are calling GF step do it this way put
the dial yeah it's a long way back and
and I just think if you're if your
intentions are not honorable and you're
not trying to do a good thing for
yourself and the customer you shouldn't
make the call if you're trying
so two things I want to point out just
to underscore first is that so you had
two offices three people but you very
adeptly gave the impression of having a
larger company oh yeah big we had this
big thing around one huge hallway and
then number two is this gambit of
so-and-so I was gonna be in town for two
days can you take the meeting if you had
said I'm based in LA and I'd love to
take the meeting in the next two days
never what happens right I don't know
why for whatever reason this
psychological judo move just works so
well it works for just about everything
to this day I'm calling from Hartford
Connecticut and I'm gonna Plainville
Connecticut that Denver Colorado's long
way off Houston Texas by the way on that
swing of ten yeah we've got two
customers
so okay I have a question so you're like
just so happens that Bill's gonna be in
Denver Colorado next week for two days
when you show up did they ever ask you
while you're in Denver Colorado because
apparently at that point they would have
figured out by then who we were yeah I
do remember though visiting TCI and I'm
not sure TC is right I do remember them
I don't know if they're still I don't I
don't know I think maybe AT&T bought
them at one point but anyway I went in
to meet with this fellow and I had my
eleven like literally when you asked
earlier I have one piece of paper
typewritten 11 lines that was my whole
pitch that was your members any of these
loving lines this is like the Holy Grail
yes not really but I mean it was we're
gonna do 24-hour sports we're gonna do
college and etc etc we're gonna be
financed by Getty we're gonna be
financed we didn't say if I get in we
expect to be the largest cable provider
Ted Turner only had three million
subscribers at that point took us a year
so past him yeah that was fun cuz I went
into me the TCI in this older gentleman
that I was meeting with I mean he was my
age but he maybe was not the rookie you
know vice president something and he had
been a broadcaster in Minneapolis and he
looked across at me and he kind of
smiled and he said you know this isn't
gonna work
he said you know we both been in the
broadcast I do know that like it's been
a work cable tell you're working 40 so
yeah well yeah he said
he admitted that so we went back and
forth a little bit and he said I'm
telling you anything he did just this he
said I'm telling you it's not gonna work
but if it does I want to be your first
customer
I thought trip to Dandridge been a
success and it was in fact the third
customer he didn't hate it make it fast
not to be the first customer so a lot of
those things just happen on the spot you
have to kind of know all of the general
areas you want to go and then stay with
it and it work and it still works for
this day this is the first is from
Facebook from Sid Jacobson why don't
they show Australian rules football the
World's Strongest Man and sticker
tournaments anymore my favorite part is
a second part of this and what happened
to those cool jackets the reporters had
doing so now that the first part I don't
know if it if it applies perfectly
because I have seen you have so many
channels now world Strongest Man for
instance but is there anything that has
been that you got rid of so you didn't
take the the rooftop no no that was our
straining rules football is actually on
ESPN Australia got it all right so
they're just found its way home yeah
it's just found its way back there are
not occasion it will will show there
there are layers of ESPN ESPN the
mothership hmm that's what they call
it's like Star Wars only it's ESPN sport
the mothership but then it's to a news
and you and XYZ and around the world but
then they have Australia and so on
and as a matter of fact it's intriguing
they show Australia the National the
cricket championship right they sent a
crew to Australia do a lot of
pre-production tape brought it back and
actually produced the cricket
championship from Bristol Connecticut
while they were playing in Australia and
you know how that works with satellites
I don't have any idea but they are
Australian rules football is I'll never
forget those guys in the white hats and
that was pretty good
never never understood it but it was
pretty good look it's a cool sport too
for those of you haven't seen it these
these athletes a lot of them have
accuracy with kicking that quarterbacks
in the US have with their with their and
those those cool jackets that have the
cool jackets you talk about the Getty
read the
orange and as soon as possible and
practicable we got rid of those no short
Lee after to check around got rid of the
Dead Poets Society / we used to have to
pin little ESPN's on those jackets they
we didn't have them embroidery because
we didn't have the budget I guess I
don't know why but wait all right well I
may have to go hunt down one of those
jackets for myself next question is from
Twitter at Neil Oh Martin I may be
saying that incorrectly what sports do
you wish were more popular on ESPN who
there's so many I mean I like college
football and I like college basketball
and Major League Baseball and I don't
know how much more they can put on yeah
they just put together a new one hundred
ninety thousand square foot digital
Center new digital Center and in there
they have one studio devoted to the NFL
only it's a half a football field
they have rising whatever and they have
things that flow down in balconies and
stair steps that you can walk up and all
over and that's that's pretty impressive
and I don't know what else they could do
for the NFL besides that I mean they're
they're doing everything except having
Roger Goodell for breakfast I guess on
we're an odd sport or esoteric sport
that you guys had on in the early days
did you have a particular favorite you
know that we had an amateur boxing
series and I've forgotten what it was
what the name who was but what I
remember about it as I was in the Dallas
Airport when they had the trains
underground not the way they are now
elevated and I was getting on a train
and I heard somebody I was just stepping
through the door and you know you step
through the door closes right behind it
I heard somebody calling me and we were
Bob Arum
Don King immediately on and that
somebody said calling my name and I
looked back and here it is he's pounding
on the windows and he wanted to talk to
me but the train pulled out and before
he ever got back in the discussion we
signed an agreement with Bob Arum some
of those crazy things and that happened
on a train if the randomness of walking
down a train stairs to get on a tram to
go to another flight the guy comes down
the door closes they lost his program
chance Wow
crazy stuff I mean that's just the way
it was it's like terrifying slash meets
like When Harry Met Sally it's kind of
like a Miss connection yeah Don King
yeah but that boxing series to answer
the question that was that was a really
interesting a lot of boxers no-name
boxers at that time a couple of my guess
did rise through the ranks that was kind
of fun I'm so glad I'm not a boxing fan
oh I am I am a huge boxing fan but also
a huge erling fan so for those of you
who haven't seen it I definitely
recommend checking out the senior
nationals of Irish early it will blow
your mind it's like football meets
lacrosse but they're playing with ax
handles and you can hit each other and
hit it like a baseball it's terrifying I
I was invited to do an interview in
Dublin we didn't fight Skype and I
agreed to do it only if the hosts would
explain to me Irish early which he did
yeah
and I used to describe it as two guys
with baseball bats on the right hand and
left hand betters boxes the ball on a
tee in the middle and somebody reaches
and throws it in the air and they both
take mighty swipes at it and hope they
miss each other I'm not so sure
sometimes they hope they miss each other
though they go right after each other
yeah if you want to see yeah yeah what
what the the Irish do when they're not
drinking Guinness and by the way the
senior nationals are sponsored by
Guinness generally so Internet don't go
crazy then you should check it out it is
fantastic we did have those by the way
at one time did you ever see that those
early red jackets that had ESPN and the
circle around it no the original I can
imagine that week I mean knowing what
the logo looks like well that happens in
the jacket it's one of the greatest
marketing stories ESPN had in the early
days let's get into it we had these red
jackets a little logo on the front they
there wasn't ESP Network it was the ESPN
with the ellipse around it and we had
the in bright red jackets and in white
on the back it had ESPN and logo and
Scottie Connell said we were
credentialed we could go to college
football games
he hired kids and gave him a notebook
and a red jacket
sent him to any game CBS was doing and
said I want one of you on the 25-yard
line one of you on the 50-yard line and
one of you on the other 25-yard line and
two more stay with the line of scrimmage
backfield on offense now if you're
familiar with the way a football game is
covered cameras around the 25 or 30 yard
line they shoot down field and there's
one high in the middle and then there's
usually some down in a field near the
back field or the line of scrimmage is
go on so every shot that CBS did that
first week had an ESPN of a free product
placement Monday morning right we're
going to sue you guys you can't do that
cannot do that Scottie said okay fine
where's CBS playing next week did the
same thing and after the second week
they called and said all right we
surrendered and so he didn't change very
much but he cut it down I guess from
five to three on their side that's about
all he did but mother advertising that
case was the necessity was the mother of
invention and that one oh that's genius
but those red jackets counted a lot I
was in the fourth grade that morning
that we had Pearl Harbor the day of
infamy and I read the Midway and Pearl
Harbor and all of the books around that
and I have a library of about it's
probably 100 to 150 books of from the
early 30s all the way through the up to
the Vietnam War Korean War the coldest
winter is one that I would recommend
David Halberstam wrote that one
coldest winter yeah and they're just I
don't know what it is I really just
enjoy reading it it's not that I'm I'm
lucky
obviously I'm lucky that I'm here and
able to do this but the things that
people have done
for us in this country are amazed this
this point I think is really important
so only in the last I would say six
months if I started reading more books
related to war specifically in this
country and one of the main reasons is
that spoken with a number of folks
including former Navy SEAL commander
named Jaco willing it was very well
known and the point that he makes is
that if you want to study human nature
you can learn and a paraphrase ofcourse
but you can learn so much by looking at
it when it's forced to these extremes
mm-hmm when you see the most
unbelievable levels of kindness the most
unbelievable levels of brutality and
everything in stark relief when you
study war and warfare so if you are a
student of human nature which of course
transcends this conversation applies to
just about anything that was one of the
points that he made and just to pull it
into say new media for a second if
people are wondering if anybody here
knows who Casey nice that is might have
a few hands he's an extremely well-known
youtuber in his hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of millions views very very
well-known filmmaker and he says that
everything he learned about business in
life he learned from studying World War
two it's that powerful well you know
there when you say that just people
don't think of America we're just here
we won the war all our planes were built
in the interior of the country because
they were worried about Japan coming to
the Pacific and German submarines were
made in Manitowoc Wisconsin you think of
a submarine why would you do a submarine
in Manitowoc with for safety because
they had German u-boats on the East
Coast and Japanese maybe they don't know
on the west coast Lake Michigan the
Naval Air Station and Plainview had an
aircraft carrier in Lake Michigan that
was where they learned to fly that's
where they got their wings it's got to
be hard to transport yeah but just think
about that Lake Michigan is right
outside Chicago playbill neighborhood
lens view naval air stations right
outside
the Navy is training in the middle of
the country for two oceans why are they
in the San Diego area or Los Angeles or
Philadelphia Naval Yard but you learn
you can really learn a lot about the the
the operation of life one thing that I
and every time I've mentioned this
somebody is surprised we always hear
about women at work during World War two
especially in the aircraft industry and
making those submarines in Manitowoc
Wisconsin the majority of the labor
force were women because they were more
able to do the delicate detail work
detail work and the wiring for the
wiring then for radio and for all of
those things but a lot different than
right today well today they wouldn't
wire that they'll be oh we had a chip
someplace but we never hear about that
yeah and it was an all-out effort
believe me so this this is going to be a
bit of a left turn but I want to ask you
about did you signal your signaling at
least left time strike oh wait I would
be terrible umpire I tell you even worse
baseball player but that's a different
story your best or one of your best or
most worthwhile investments you've ever
made and I want to explain what I mean
by that it could be money could be time
could be energy could be anything and an
example that comes from someone I've
chatted with separately is Amelia Boone
so Amelia Boone's a three-time world's
toughest mutter champion she's the most
decorated obstacle course racer in the
world also a full-time attorney at Apple
she's one of the most impressive humans
I've ever met and her answer to that was
the entrance fee for her first major
competition which was I think about $450
a huge stretch at the time for her but
she did it and it produced this
incredible open door and trajectory to
something she never would have
anticipated what are one of your best
investments that night I was not a
credit card cash advance
I have to tell you I have to tell you a
brief story about that I spoke to a
group of Merrill Lynch and he was Bank
of America all senior executives in
Greenwich Connecticut some couple years
ago and one of the topics that came up
in the discussion because these banks
like to lend money and you should have
bank loans to start your business and we
will work with you and we'll do you know
I'm not I'm not a hundred percent
subscriber that so when it was my turn
to speak I get up and I said well first
of all you'll all be happy to know that
I started ESPN with bank financing and
they were all sitting every single one
of them a tie in pinstripe suits and so
on I said well it depends on how you
define financing it was a nine thousand
dollar credit card cash it's well that
was talk about an icebreaker
that got me through them and but the
real thing that got me through that
group was there are a couple of Hartford
Whaler from the New England Whaler fans
in the audience that sounded that sealed
the deal
but to me to speak to a group like that
they all and I hope I'm not insulting
anyone in the audience watching or
sitting here today there is a certain
confidence a certain bearing and feeling
that think people have because they help
others down below them and as I walked
into the room I was the oldest guy in
the room they were all like some of my
kids age so they weren't intimidating to
me at all I we started talking before
the meeting was over there loosening
their ties and we had just a great great
session with them and which I think
reaching people is part of what you have
to do too
so I want to talk I want to talk about
reaching people in a very particular
instance so when you got that cash
advance $9,000 cash advance on a credit
card were you married
were you sick oh yeah okay so now three
kids compliment college matters so in
today's dollars I don't know what that
would be it's maybe 40 grand I'm just
pulling a number out yeah I have no what
was that was that a lot of money for you
guys at the time and was that a
conversation that you well let me let me
put it in context we had a drawer in the
kitchen a little counter and so on and
the checkbook was in there you know
because then we wrote wrote check we
didn't have all this internet stuff it
couldn't be
no bill payer right and I was writing a
checking my youngest son walked by me
and he said is everything all right you
know he was kind of concerned and I was
because I had the checkbook laying there
and we open the checkbook it was just
before payday
he said that can't be right and there
were 17 cents in the bank account no not
not in the bank but in the checkbook
right 17 cents and he said are you
worried I said why well that's not gonna
you know we're not going far he was a
maybe a junior in college at that point
but I never I never had any doubt
because payday came and I know something
else would happen as I ended it
obviously did was your wife worried girl
no no no no she was she knew the 11
bullet points she knew all of it right
down the line yeah she was there for 56
years he was there so it was okay that's
incredible
[Applause]
if we had a golf ball how to ask you
about golf with one of this country's
presidents I was hoping you could maybe
tell us a little bit about golf I think
it was with George yeah George 41 so
tell us about I think there's one putt
in particular well yeah I would maybe I
was a little irreverent but well yeah I
was invited to play with President Bush
in Naples Florida and and just a great
guy we went out and met the only
appropriate people went to the driving
range did all that had pictures you know
a thousand pictures taken and so on and
then we started playing and we all hit
on the green first green and and he was
maybe I don't know three or four feet
from the from the hole and he was a
golfer Huestis long a long putter where
he put it up under his chin and gave the
you know putting like this he kept
swinging back and forth and and like
okay who's gonna give me the putt you
know because I guess you're supposed to
buy that so after about the fourth time
he stepped back again they looked over
at us and I I don't know why I said it I
just one of those things I said
presidential privilege only goes so far
putt
so he looked up and he smiled and he
said game on and so we had a $2.00 bet
for the game and I had to put this long
at the on the 18th and obviously since
he didn't get the first we would about
to get and I missed it and he made his
butt and won the hole and won the $2 and
took the ball out and he said I want you
to have this in honor of losing $2 to me
yeah but I I don't know why I said that
to him it was probably inappropriate but
he cracked does this seems to have
turned out pretty well when you fly fly
by the cuff yeah hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me and would you enjoy getting a
short email for me every Friday event
provides a little morsel of fun before
the weekend and 500 Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour work week calm
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by 4
Sigma Dec founded by the genius Finn's
who lit the internet on fire and you may
have heard of their mushroom coffee
which features chaga and lion's mane
which has taken Silicon Valley by storm
I use it pretty
every day either that or the chaga which
is decaf of a separate version and I use
both of these primarily for focus and
productivity they just get you going let
you up like a Christmas tree you should
definitely check it out people are
always asking me what I use for
cognitive enhancement and for right now
this is the answer I try to force this
on all of my houseguests it is a hell of
a thing if I have employees or people
come over who are working on projects
with me I always try to feed it to them
because I'm going to get the limitless
effect it's a lot more out of them the
first time I mentioned this product and
for sig Matic on the podcast your
products sold out in less than a week so
you may want to check them out soon if
you're listening to this and the coffee
tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner of my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic calm
forward slash Tim that's for sig Matic
fo you are SI g ma TI c calm forward
slash Tim and use the code tim TI m to
get 20% off of your first order and
they're not that expensive anyway if you
are in the experimental mindset I do not
think you'll be disappointed to try them
out this episode is brought to you by a
scent protein I am really excited about
this discovery I became aware of these
guys when I found out that they'd spent
five years trying to manufacture a
better version of whey protein and the
result is something called native
proteins which represents cleaner pure
less processed protein so here's a mini
tutorial there are only a handful of
companies worldwide
that can extract native proteins
directly from milk traditional whey
protein what you've probably bought
before is a byproduct of making cheese
so a company must have the resources
know-how and a large customer base to
invest in extracting proteins directly
from the milk without the ability to
also profit from the associated cheese
that means the net-net is native
proteins are super rare so a scent is
the only us-based company that offers
native proteins both way and micellar
casein directly be a consumer they're
able to do that because the parent
company labrie know is a huge cheese
manufacturer
they've been filtering proteins for more
than 30 years and there are a few
important things to take away from this
number one zero artificial ingredients
that is a solid claim it's much stricter
than all natural number two they've done
extensive testing so the chocolate which
I've been using after every workout and
also in the mornings was finalized after
282 recipes reporter vetted and perhaps
most important I talked about less
processed they avoid steps like
bleaching and this is important to
understand so it's it's a very big deal
that hasn't yet caught on for Sports
Nutrition traditional whey proteins are
a byproduct of cheese making like I
mentioned many of the proteins are
therefore orange in color because they
were sourced from say cheddar cheese
production because companies can't sell
orange powder as vanilla or strawberry
they have to bleach the proteins white
this harms the proteins and leaves trace
amounts of bleach in the product that is
no bueno
no good infant formula companies for
instance to ban the use of bleached
proteins already in their products and
that is why a sense parent company
Macrina foods is the number one supplier
of cooking to infinite formula companies
so all that said you want cleaner pure
less processed protein I certainly do
and I'm really excited to be using this
protein and I just ran out of chocolate
so I need another bag check it out
go to a scent protein dot-com forward
slash Tim that's a SC ent protein comm
scent protein compote / Tim and you can
receive 20% off of your entire
order you want a quick 25 gram dose to
start your day for instance you're
falling slow carb diet or after a
workout this is a great option they also
have micellar casein which is slower
release and you can check that out
so take a look go to ascent protein com2
forward slash
[Music]
[Applause]